à Montmagny cet étudiante en technique
d'éducation à l'enfance se laisse
charmer au Salon de l'Emploi du
regroupement des CPE de Québec et de
chaudière à chat j'ai plein de dépliages
aujourd'hui parce que les les
directrices ne veut pas ils cherchent
les éducateurs si les occasions d'emploi
sont multiples aujourd'hui elles le
seront encore plus dans les prochaines
années avec l'ouverture de nouvelles
places en centre de la petite enfance
d'ici 2025 il faudra recruter 2000
nouvelles éducatrices en deux ans je le
vois déjà que c'est un peu mentalement
difficile pour les éducatrices de devoir
c'est des fois c'est pas rare que tu
fais du temps supplémentaire est-ce
qu'on aura le personnel pour ses places
là
c'est là que le bob laisse car la relève
se fait de plus en plus rare au Cégep de
Sainte-Foy près de 1900 étudiants ont
obtenu leur diplôme au cours des 10
dernières années s'ils étaient 207
diplômés en 2017 ce nombre a chuté à 150
l'an dernier les inscriptions sont aussi
à la baisse depuis 10 ans au campus
Notre-Dame de Foix un point tel que la
Cour 2022 n'a jamais démarré dès la
première année les milieux veulent les
avoir en deuxième année veulent les
avoir on a de la misère à les rendre en
parce que tellement une pénurie sur le
marché du travail actuellement moi j'ai
commencé ma technique on était à peu
près à 80 étudiants d'inscrits et là je
suis en deuxième année dernière session
puis on est à 34 on est allé réaliste on
sait que ça va être difficile
ça nous inquiète malgré l'inquiétude le
regroupement des CPE de la région croit
que le gouvernement doit garder le cap
dans la création de ces nouvelles places
on est convaincu que ces places là sont
essentiels alors on travaille fort pour
essayer de
se définitivement un défi on le voit la
ministre de la Famille avoue que la
tâche s'annonce ardue il y a des bourses
qui sont offerts il y a des possibilités
de formation travailler dessus il y a la
reconnaissance des acquis qui est mis en
place et on continue de soutenir des
initiatives on travaille aussi en
recrutement international autant
d'enjeux qui semble donner raison à une
telle campagne de séduction ici Louis
Simon Lapointe Radio-Canada Québec